Knitting in fairisle or two colors across
each row is a staple
technique for machine knitters.
Placing yarn in each yarn feeder
of the carriage and setting
the machine correctly.
You can knit stranded knitting
in a fraction of the time
as knitting it by hand.
Start by knitting a few
rows in plain knitting
end with the carriage on the left.
Lock the card on the first row.
By setting the card lock
lever to the circle.
Engage the patterning device
by setting the change knob to KC
and knit from left to right.
Notice that there are needles in working
position B and middle position D.
Press the upper MC button to tell the
carriage you want to knit in Fairisle.
Release the card lock
lever with the triangle.
This will allow the punch card to advance.
Thread the second yarn in the mast
and position it in the B feeder.
Now you don't need to open the gate.
Just snap the yarn into place, wiggle it
around to make sure it flows smoothly.
Hold that new yarn with your
left hand and begin knitting.
Notice that the yarns are being carried
across the back of the knitting.
As you pass the carriage,
following the punch card,
needles are being selected for the next
row, and both colors are being
knit in turn across the row.
As you pass the carriage, the punch card
automatically advances to the next row.
This pattern repeats every two rows,
alternating the colors
according to the punch card.